now I know you're going to give the next
speaker a very warm welcome but when you
do so could I ask you to add to that
welcome your views your thanks
on the way that the next speaker LED
this country through the two-year Worst
Years of the pandemic the leadership
resilience and fortitude that she showed
ladies and gentlemen the leader of the
Scottish national party the first
minister of Scotland Nicholas Roger SNP
foreign
yeah
my friends it is so good to be speaking
at conference in person again rather
than just virtually
getting to hug friends and colleagues is
so so much better
our political family
Scotland's biggest party by far is back
together again and that feels great
now the only downside of not being on
Zoom is having to trade my slippers for
these heels
but I suppose I can't have absolutely
everything
of course it is always good to be here
in Aberdeen
especially especially now that the SNP
is once again leading this great City
Aberdeen and the Northeast is at the
heart of our just transition to innate
zero future
since our late Queen whose extraordinary
life of service we have honored in
recent weeks switched on the 40s
pipeline in
1975. oil and gas has powered the
Scottish economy
her late Majesty back then inaugurated
the oil and gas age
as we move now in so many ways into a
new era we have a duty to repay all
those who work in that industry a duty
a duty to support them into new jobs in
Green energy an opportunity to usher in
the new age of Scottish Renewables
conference Aberdeen is the oil and gas
capital of Europe letters resolve today
to now make it the Net Zero capital of
the world
that ambition led us to establish the
500 million pounds just transition fund
for this region today I can announce the
first 22 projects have just been awarded
funding of more than 50 million pounds
foreign
these projects will support the
production of green hydrogen the
development of wave and tidal technology
and even Pioneer the use of waste from
whiskey to recycle EV batteries
they will focus on the skills our
existing Workforce need to take
advantage of the Renewables Revolution
incredible Scottish Ingenuity here in
the Northeast supported by the Scottish
government developing Technologies to
tackle the global climate emergency it
is exciting inspiring stuff and it is a
shining example of what a Scottish
government can do when the powers lie in
our hands
thank you
conference when we last gathered
together just weeks from the start of a
global pandemic we could not have
imagined quote lay ahead
thankfully covered no longer dominates
the news or our thoughts quite as much
as it did
but the virus still poses a risk
especially as we approach winter
so before I go any further today a plea
if you are eligible get your booster
Jack vaccination is just as important
now as it was last winter
if you don't do it for yourself though
you really really should
do it for those more vulnerable than you
and please do it for the National Health
Service we owe the NHS and all who work
in it a massive debt of gratitude
thank you
conference all of us hoped that when the
worst of the pandemic was over better
times would lie ahead
thanks to the Brilliance of vaccine
scientists
and the sheer strength of the human
spirit I am certain those better days
will come
but in the midst of a cost of living
crisis it won't surprise you to hear me
talk today about the challenges we face
and about the massive responsibility of
me and my government to help you through
it
as we navigate these Stormy Waters
Scotland needs a steady and
compassionate hand on the tiller
conference that is what our Scottish
government provides
but today
I will also make the case for optimism
for not just accepting the world as it
is
but turning our minds and our hearts
instead to building a stronger Scotland
and playing our part in building a
better fairer world
the optimism that a better world is
possible is inspired for me by The
Bravery of those who endure the toughest
of times
and at home by the knowledge that this
beautiful magnificent country of ours is
bursting with Talent creativity and
ingenuity
we also have a sense of solidarity and
common purpose that yes our political
debate can sometimes obscure
conference Scotland has got what it
takes to be a successful independent
country it has it in abundance never let
anyone tell us otherwise
of course at this moment across the
world that better future can be hard to
see eclipsed as it is by significant and
profound challenges
a war of unprovoked aggression on our
continent
an energy price crisis and soaring
inflation
Democratic Norms eroded and human rights
attacked in too many countries
in the face of that we have a duty to
Champion Progressive values and
Universal rights friends that is a duty
our party will always discharge
but in the UK we have a Westminster
government intent on taking us down a
different path
the current home secretary is speaking
at the Conservative Party Conference
said this about Asylum Seekers
and even as I quote her I struggle to
comprehend that she actually said these
words
but here they are
I would love to be having a front page
of the telegraph with a plane taking off
to Rwanda
that's my dream it's my obsession
conference
my dream is very different
I'm sure it is shared in this Hall and
by the vast majority across Scotland
my dream is that we live in a world
where those fleeing violence and
depression are shown compassion and
treated like human beings not showing
the door and bundled onto planes like
unwanted cargo
thank you
friends
a case for Hope and optimism rests above
all on our common Humanity
compassion solidarity love
these values sustained Us in the darkest
days of the pandemic they must drive us
forward now
those fighting across the globe for
democracy equality and human dignity
must hear that they are not alone
so let the message go out from us to
everyone across the world standing up
against tyranny and depression we stand
with you
to women in Iran fighting for basic
human rights we stand with you
to get us
to girls in Afghanistan demanding the
right to go to school we stand with you
to men and women risking their lives in
opposition to put in in Russia or his
sidekick in Belarus we stand with you
and to the people of Ukraine fighting
for your very existence we stand with
you
all right
today we live on a continent
with a so-called strong man the one who
has never looked weaker or more insecure
has launched a brutal invasion of his
neighbor
that should be unimaginable in 21st
century Europe
but for the people of Ukraine it is all
too real
every day there are atrocities and
killings today the capital cave and
cities across the country are under
renewed bombardment
despicable war crimes have been
committed and Conference let us be clear
these are war crimes for which Vladimir
Putin must be held to account
the contrast between Putin and the
people of Ukraine could not be Starker
from president zielinski to the
sacrifice of ordinary citizens
personified here on Saturday by Our
Guest Lydia vasilenko we have seen
incredible bravery and extraordinary
determination Ukraine you had an
inspiration to the world and we will
always stand with you
conference we are not on the front line
of this war but Ukraine's victory in the
battle between democracy and tyranny is
vital for all of us
the Scottish government will continue to
do everything we can to help
we're helping enforce sanctions and
isolate Russia we have provided funds
for Vital military equipment and we have
opened Scotland's doors to those
displeased initially we committed to
welcoming 3 000 people seeking Refuge
from the war I am pleased to see that we
are now providing safety for more than
twenty thousand
to each and every one our hearts go out
to you
we know you yearn to go home but for as
long as you need a place of sanctuary be
in no doubt you have a home here in
Scotland
conference there are moments in history
as now with Ukraine when all of us must
be prepared to make sacrifices to help
defend fundamental freedoms
but when Global turbulence strikes
National governments have a duty to act
in ways that mitigate rather than
exacerbate the impacts on their own
populations
when it comes to the cost of living
crisis and so much else besides this UK
government is utterly feeling in that
Duty
each and every day its actions are
making matters worse
we last gather together as a party in
October 2019
back then the Tories had just elected a
new leader
Westminster Wars in meltdown
a new prime minister was driving through
a disastrous policy agenda despite
warnings of its dire economic impact
and here we are all over again another
spin on the Tory misery go round
but this time this time the Charis Hill
is speeding up
it took the Tories three years three
long years to realize that Boris Johnson
was a disaster with less trust it took
them just three weeks
she caused me him in the markets with
her decision to borrow billions of
pounds to fund tax cuts for the richest
borrowing to be repaid by eye-watering
austerity cuts and a raid on the incomes
of the poorest it is unconscionable
thank you
the prime minister's justification is
that she is going for growth conference
let me tell you what kind of growth that
will be growth in the gap between rich
and poor growth in the rates of poverty
growth in the pressure on our NHS and
other public services and without any
doubt growth in the Deep disgust that
the public feel for all of it
the truth is massive handouts for the
wealthiest at the expense of everyone
else do nothing for the economy all they
do is Turbo Charge inequality
so let me be clear about this no SNP
government will ever inflict on Scotland
such an immoral self-defeating disaster
of a policy
instead we will continue to use our
powers and resources to help those most
in need and not as an act of Charity but
in our Collective interest
conference here is what I stand for what
we stand for
not hoping against all evidence to the
contrary that wealth will suddenly and
magically start trickling down
but instead lifting people up so they
can contribute their full potential that
is the snp's founding principle for a
stronger economy
I am proud of the work the Scottish
government is doing to tackle child
poverty the Scottish child payment is
unique in the United Kingdom it is paid
to eligible families with children up to
age six it started at 10 pounds per week
at conference last year I announced we
would double it to 20. friends five
weeks from today we will increase it
again to 25 pounds a week
vital financial help from more than 100
000 children delivered in time for
Christmas
on the same day we increase the payment
we will also extend it to families with
children up to age 16. now conference
I
I know I'm a bit biased
but I think that's a sign of a
government with the right priorities
but we need
we need to do more because we know this
winter is going to be really tough
rather than looking forward to Christmas
too many families will be dreading it
dreading it because they don't know if
they can afford to heat their homes or
even pay for food
it's part of our help to the poorest
families over the past year we have made
quarterly bridging payments of 130
pounds these have gone to children and
young people in receipt of free School
meals but who don't qualify for the
child payment
today I can announce that the final
installment ahead of the extension of
the child payment and due in the next
few weeks will not be 130 pounds we will
double it to 260 pounds
friends
that will help put food on the Christmas
table for families of 145 000 children
and young people now I don't pretend it
will make all of their worries go away
no government with our limited powers
can ever do that but I do hope this
investment of almost 20 million pounds
will bring a bit of Christmas cheer to
those who need it most
conference we have used the powers of
our Parliament to deliver the unique
child payment
last Thursday we took further action to
help combat the cost of living crisis
the Scottish government's emergency Bill
to protect tenants was passed by
parliament the result A ranked freeze in
operation in Scotland over the winter
until at least the end of March next
year
but as we have acted to help those in
need what about the UK government
you know it is difficult to overstate
the Calamity of their actions
back in 2014 the Westminster
establishment told us that it was the
UK's standing in the world its economic
strength
and its stability that made Independence
impossible
now they say it's the UK's isolation its
weakness and instability the very
conditions they created that means
change can't happen
as far as Westminster is concerned it
heads the wind and Tails we lose but
this time it will not wash
because what that is delivering for
Scotland is this brexit more austerity
homeowners facing real hardship and
hundreds of thousands in poverty
conference that is not strength and
stability it is chaos and catastrophe
and Friends
all of that is on the Tories
but we should remember that their
ability to do it has too often been
aided and abetted by labor
2014 labor joined forces with the Tories
they said then that Westminster Tori
government was better for Scotland than
self-government and Incredibly they are
doing it all over again it wasn't easy
to understand back then
but given everything that has happened
since it is utterly inexplicable now
take brexit
imposed on Scotland against our will and
doing real lasting damage to our
interests our economy and our young
people
labor is now just as committed to brexit
a hard brexit as the Tories
you know at least the Tories believe in
it
labor doesn't
yet rather than make the principled
argument which they could actually now
win in England they cower away from it
they abandon all principle for fear of
upsetting the apple cart bluntly they
are willing to Chuck Scotland under
Boris Johnson's brexit bus to get the
keys to Downing Street
friends
letting down Scotland same old labor
for Scotland there is a fundamental
Democratic issue here and it has real
life consequences whether it's Tori or
labor labor or Tori it's not us who gets
to decide
our votes don't determine who gets to
occupy number 10.
for Scotland the problem is not just
which party is in power at Westminster
the problem is Westminster
and to fix that
to make sure we get the governments that
the largest number of us vote for always
not just occasionally for that my
friends we need Scotland's Independence
foreign
for Any Nation
but it is about hope for a better future
we all want Scotland to be a country in
which no child goes to bed hungry
a place where everyone can afford to
heat their home
where our vast energy resources benefit
all who live here and help save the
planet
none of that should be radical
but it must be the foundation of
everything we aspire to
for this long
but as long as I am first minister
by the way conference I intend that to
be for quite some time yet
foreign
for as long as I am first Minister I
will do everything in my power to build
the better Scotland we all want to see
now I know some people ask
and it is not an illegitimate question
why propose a referendum in the midst of
a cost of living crisis conference the
answer is in the question
the answer is the cost of living crisis
[Applause]
it is the Tory response to it it is the
financial chaos and it is the damage of
brexit
all of that is laying beer each and
every single day the harm being done to
people in Scotland because we are not
independent
foreign
the next two days
the Supreme Court will consider whether
the current law allows the Scottish
Parliament to legislate for an advisory
referendum
if Westminster had any respect at all
for Scottish democracy this court
hearing would not be necessary
but Westminster has no such respect
that means this issue was always
destined to end up in court sooner or
later better in my view that it is
sooner if the Court decides
if the Court decides in the way we hope
it does on 19th October next year there
will be an independent referendum
thank you
and if the court doesn't decide that way
well first and obviously we will respect
that judgment we believe in the rule of
law
and as a party and a movement we will of
course reflect but fundamentally it will
leave us with a very simple Choice put
our case for Independence to the people
in an election or give up on Scottish
democracy conference I don't know about
you actually I suspect I do know about
you but I will never ever give up on
Scottish democracy
thank you
for now the question of process
the how of securing Independence is in
the hands of Judges but it is for us to
crack on with answering the question why
polls last week show that support for
Independence is rising but remember
polls are just momentary snapshots and
time they go up and they cool down much
more significant are the findings of the
latest British social attitude survey
ten years ago support for Independence
was at 23 percent
five years ago 45 percent
now in that gold standard measure of
public opinion support for Independence
stands at 52 percent
as we know it is even higher amongst
young people
so it is tempting sometimes to assume an
inevitability about independence that
the Arc of history is moving firmly in
its direction I hope and believe that
will turn out to be true
but we would be wrong utterly wrong to
take it for granted
our job is to meet the case and win the
argument
that means
that means not just talking to ourselves
but reaching out to others not yet
persuaded
I remember in the 2014 campaign speaking
at a public meeting in Leith it was
jam-packed so busy in fact that the
organizers asked those who had already
decided to vote Yes to leave so that
those still undecided could hear the
arguments
that is the approach I want us to take
now though for the avoidance of doubt I
am not asking you to get up and leave
but I do want us to resolve today that
from here on we will speak less to each
other and more to those outside our
ranks
I know that some watching at home right
now will never be persuaded to vote yet
you oppose Independence as strongly and
from as much Principle as we support it
I respect that that is democracy and
please remember whatever happens in
future Scotland belongs to you as much
as it does to us Scotland belongs to all
of us
thank you
and for those who want to be convinced
but still have questions and doubts it
is our job to persuade reassure and
inspire
conference one of the great ironies of
the independence debate
is that so many of the institutions that
people associate with britishness
institutions that have shaped our shared
history like the NHS a fair Social
Security System Public Service
broadcasting the threat to these
institutions comes not from an
independent Scotland it comes from UK
governments that are dismantling or
undermining these institutions
thank you
with Independence we can do more to
protect them let's take one of those
institutions our most precious public
service
the NHS is under enormous pressure right
now it delivers outstanding care within
waiting time targets for the vast
majority of those who need it today I
want us to pay tribute to each and every
individual who works within our National
Health Service
but the pressures on the NHS mean that
despite their dedication too many people
are waiting too long that is why we are
delivering record investment and it is
why we are doing everything we can to
give our NHS workers a fair pay rise
because conference few in our society
deserve it more than they do
fast diagnosis and reliable equality
Health Care matters whatever your
condition but it is especially important
for those with cancer
the best chance of surviving cancer
remains early detection and treatment
over the past year we have established
three new Fast Track cancer diagnostic
Centers inertia and Aaron the facing
Galloway and Fife they have already
supported hundreds of patients more than
one in seven were found to have cancer
and around half of them were from the
poorest parts of our country so these
centers are helping tackle Health
inequality too conference Fast Track
cancer diagnosis centers work that's why
I'm delighted to confirm today that two
more centers will open next year one in
the borders and one in lanarkshire
thank you
and by the end of this Parliament there
will be a fast track cancer diagnosis
Center in every Health Board in Scotland
that is just one example of how we are
supporting our NHS that job is the most
important our government has right now
management of the NHS is our
responsibility it is no one else's
but the fact is our ability to fund it
properly depends on decisions taken at
Westminster when they cut our budget or
when they crash our economy that makes
it harder for us to protect the Health
Service and if some Tories are now
openly arguing they move away from the
very basis on which it was founded and
towards an insurance-based alternative
that will destroy our National Health
Service with Independence that will
never happen
we
we will always protect its founding
principles you know with Independence we
could choose to embed a universal nhf in
a written Constitution a constitutional
right to Health Care free at the point
of need conference if the SNP is in
government that is exactly what we will
do
thank you
friends
I know that some see Independence as
turning our back on the rest of the UK
it is not
it is about recasting a relationship as
one of equals
across these islands we share history
family connections and friendships these
things matter just as much to supporters
of Independence as to anyone else in
fact I am willing to bet that the
nations of these islands will work
together even better with Independence
than we do now
Scotland will still be a member of the
British Irish Council the difference is
that like the Republic of Ireland now we
will be there as an independent country
you know
there is a point here that at first
glance might seem curious
but in my view it is becoming
increasingly true
Independence is actually the best way to
protect the partnership on which the
United Kingdom was founded a voluntary
Partnership of Nations
foreign
right now right now and make no mistake
about this it is an aggressive unionism
that is undermining that partnership
westminster's denial of Scottish
democracy
full frontal attacks on Devolution a
basic lack of respect if there is
tension that is what is causing it it is
it is my friends
Scottish independence a new partnership
of the Isles that can renew the whole
idea of our Nations working together for
the common good
Scotland Wales the island of Ireland we
will always be the closest of friends we
will always be family but we can achieve
a better relationship a true Partnership
of equals when we win Scotland's
Independence
foreign
I am well aware that what gives many
people most pause for thought on
Independence is the economy
people can see all too clearly now that
the UK does not offer economic strength
or Financial Security
and yet still and rightly they want to
know that Independence will make
Scotland's economy stronger not weaker
that is fair and especially now that is
entirely understandable
of course it is equally fair to point
out that so much of the uncertainty and
crisis we face is not because of
Independence it is the opposite once
again it is because we are not
independent
conference
Independence is not a medical economic
cure
but let this message ring out today we
can do better than this we can do so
much better than this
and let's remember let's remember these
three basic facts first Scotland is not
benefiting right now from the so-called
broad shoulders of the United Kingdom
seconds and let there be no doubt about
this we have got everything it takes to
be a successful independent country
extraordinary resources Industries and
talent in abundance and third
Independence is not an untested idea
Independence is normal
thank you
for countries of Scotland's size or even
smaller Independence is an outstanding
success
earlier this year the Scottish
government published evidence
illustrating that point
conference listen now to these facts and
then think of the untapped potential
Scotland has
compared to the UK these other countries
with so many similarities to Scotland
are welfare moriko they have higher
productivity lower poverty rates lower
child poverty and lower pension or
poverty they have higher Social Mobility
they spend more on research and
development they have higher business
investment in short these countries
combine economic dynamism with social
solidarity they're amongst the most
successful societies the world has ever
known and it is their success not a
failing UK economy that Scotland must
now aim to match
with Independence we won't emulate that
success overnight but the big burning
question is this
if all of these countries can achieve
all of that why not Scotland
conference I can confirm that one week
today we will publish the next in our
building a new Scotland series of papers
it will make the economic case for
Independence
we'll set out how we can build a new
sustainable Economy based on our massive
renewable energy resources it will show
how in an energy rich independent
Scotland we can deliver lower prices and
stronger security of supply and on
energy let me give this commitment
unlike our UK counterparts the Scottish
government will not be issuing licensees
for fracking
in the economic prospectus we will set
out how in an independent Scotland we
can secure Fair work we will repeal
westminster's anti-trade Union
legislation
we will end
we will end age discrimination for those
on the minimum wage
we will show how businesses can benefit
from Independence
with EU membership they'll be back
inside the world's biggest single Market
with a fairer migration policy and
freedom of movement restored they will
have access to workers from Europe and
across the world they will have new
opportunities to influence government
policy through a social partnership
approach in short we will show how we
can break with the low productivity High
inequality
brexit-based UK economy and use the full
powers of Independence to build an
inclusive fear well-being economy that
works for everyone an economy that works
for everyone that is the prize of
Independence
conference moving to Independence and
making it work will of course take time
hard work and good judgment there will
be many challenges along the way our
economic prospectus will be clear on
these two
the past three weeks have taught us
anything it is that a country's fiscal
and monetary policy must be sustainable
and command confidence we will not shy
away from that our approach to borrowing
with the new powers of Independence will
be responsible and for a purpose let me
give one example of that a central
proposal in the paper we will publish
next week we propose to invest remaining
oil revenues and use our borrowing
Powers not to cut tax for the richest
but to set up an independence investment
fund
foreign
the building and New Scotland fund will
deliver up to 20 billion pounds of
investment in the first decade of
Independence
in Practical terms a fund like this
could support a massive program to
decarbonize housing cut fuel bills and
reduce fuel poverty it could Finance the
building of thousands more affordable
homes invest in local renewable energy
projects helping communities own assets
and wield more influence over their use
it will help the transition to Net Zero
build resilient communities and
kick-start the sustainable economic
growth so important for our newly
independent nation combining Scotland's
abundant resources with the powers of
Independence to benefit this and future
Generations conference that is what
Independence is all about
my friends a week ago
one of the most famous men in the
history of the independence movement in
Hamilton died at the ripe old age of 97.
as a young man in 1950 Ian together with
K Matheson Gavin Vernon and Alan Stewart
repatriated the stone of Destiny from
Westminster Abbey
Ian once called it and absolutely
Splendid Adventure
I am sure it was that
but it was so much more besides
in 1950 and to be frank for years
afterwards Independence must have seemed
like an Impossible Dream
all of us here today have a big job
still to do to win independence but we
no longer face such impossible odds
friends we are the independence
generation
foreign
ERS of the cause kept Alive by Ian
Hamilton and his generation
and I believe firmly in my head and in
my heart that we will be the first in
the modern world to live in an
independent Scotland
foreign
let me tell you why I see that
a couple of weeks ago I had a
conversation with a woman that summed up
a question I think a lot of people have
she said that she would like Scotland to
be independent she thought it would be
good
which also worried that getting there
would be hard
so her question was this is it essential
and that got me thinking
for many people like Kian like all of us
in this Hall we just believe it is right
that Scotland could and should be an
independent nation
but is it essential
conference today probably more than at
any time in my life the answer to that
question is yes
foreign
Independence is essential
it is essential to escape Westminster
control and mismanagement essential to
get the governments we vote for to
properly protect our NHS to build a new
partnership of equals with the other
nations on these islands it is essential
if we want to be back in the European
Union
and it is essential if we want the
people who live here to determine the
future of this extraordinary country
the country that always tugs at her
heartstrings the country that we all
care
so much about
there are two things that we the
independence generation
must never ever lose faith in they have
sustained Us in good times and bad
throughout all the years and decades
first is the fundamental right of the
nation of Scotland to self-determination
and the second is what history
teaches us and that is the overwhelming
power of democracy to Triumph
my friends the period ahead will see
some of the greatest challenges our
country has faced in many years
but a great opportunity is also in sight
an opportunity to win and build the
better future we know is possible a
better future as an independent nation
welcoming diverse full of love and
compassion in these tough times let us
Inspire with hope in our hearts let us
lift our eyes put our shoulders to the
wheel and build a better future for this
and generations to come friends
with optimism
confidence and determination we can now
finish the job and we will thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]